- [Instructor] After a rain
storm, Lily measures the depth
of several puddles in her backyard.
She records her results in a table.
So here are three different
puddles and she measures
the depth in inches.
We're asked how much deeper
was the puddle under the swing
than the puddle on the sidewalk.
So pause this video and see
if you can figure that out.
So they say how much deeper
was the puddle under the swing,
so that's this one right over
here it's one and 1/4 inches
deep it's under the swing.
How much deeper was that than
the puddle on the sidewalk?
Do that in a different color,
the puddle on the sidewalk.
And we see here the puddle
on the sidewalk is 2/4 inches
deep, so what we could
do is subtract the 2/4
from the one and 1/4.
So we could write one and
1/4 minus 2/4 could write it
like that, and we could try
to subtract the fraction part
2/4 from the fraction part
of this mixed number up here
from 1/4 but we immediately
have a problem 'cause 2/4
is a larger fraction than 1/4,
so how do we deal with that?
Well the key is to realize
that one can be rewritten
as a fraction, one and 1/4
is the same thing as one plus
1/4 which is the same thing
as another way to write one
in terms of fourths is 4/4
so this is 4/4 plus 1/4
which is going to be equal to 5/4.
So now you can do this as
5/4, this number is the same
thing as 5/4 minus 2/4, let
me rewrite it, minus 2/4,
minus two over four.
And that's pretty
straightforward if I have five of
something and I subtract
two of it, I'm going to have
three of that something in this
case I'm talking about 3/4.
So this is going to be 3/4 so
how much deeper was the puddle
under the swing than the
puddle on the sidewalk?
Well 3/4 of an inch.
And just another way that you
could have visualized this
is look I'm going to subtract
2/4 from one and 1/4.
At first we could've thought
of one and 1/4 as a whole like
this and then it's all let me
shade it, the whole and that's
one and then I would have a
fourth of a whole so let me
divide this into four sections,
so this is one and 1/4.
And at first we say well how
do we take away 2/4 from just
that I only have 1/4 right over
here and our key realization
is well look, I actually
this whole right over here
is actually 4/4 I can think of
it as 4/4, so I can think of
it like this and now I have
5/4, one, two, three, four, five
fourths and now I can take
away two of the fourths,
so I can take away one of the
fourths and two of the fourths
and what am I left with?
Well then I am going to
be left with these 3/4
right over there.